I defined my software through my net
worth for the vast majority of my career
despite knowing that it is not the best
way to do it I'm a big believer that the
measuring stick that we choose to use is
the filter that we decide what paths to
take throughout our life and we measure
them against this lens of will it help
me accomplish this measuring step
whatever the thing is and for me was
will this build my net worth and it has
worked for that goal that being said
when I look at my 85 year old self back
into today I don't think that that man
would care if he had 50 more net worth
and so I feel like my decision calculus
has recently begun to change will this
build Goodwill